ihr wisst ich setze in diesem projekt
mehr auf wir gehen das ganze ruhig an
und gelassen
ein wunderschöner neuer tag erwartet uns
hier in unserer minecraft welt meine
lieben freunde ich habe mir fürs heutige
der adidas scheißen ein schild ja immer
noch hier ich habe mir zwar eigentlich
gesagt dass ich alles was ich in diesem
projekt mache also beispielsweise dinge
abbau oder erkunde auch wirklich
aufnehmen und auf youtube hochladen
jedoch
kisten sortierung von leider habe ich
hier schon mal ein bisschen was sortiert
hier sind zum beispiel meine ganzen
seltenen sachen hier sind meine ganzen
seltenen sachen drin hier vorne habe ich
gar nichts drin hier habe ich auch
nichts drin hier habe ich so sachen zum
bauen habe ich hier drin und hier habe
ich so krims krams ja ich bin nicht so
gut im sortieren wenn man dann
allerdings runter geht habe ich hier
unten auch noch ein bisschen was gemacht
und zwar in unserem kleinen kellerraum
hier das ganze essen reingepackt und
hier alles was mit waffen zu tun hat da
sind oft direkt schon beim thema meine
lieben freunde wir können nämlich mal
eben kurz die die farm so ein bisschen
wieder beisammen haben sondern halt
wasser was wir mit den kartoffeln so
richtig machen wollen weiß ich nicht
aber es ist ja besser dass man die hat
als dass man die nicht hat von daher
pflanzen willst wie ja den ganzen
apparat hier mal voll dann haben wir
auch wieder ganz ganz viele auf der
heutigen liste also wir haben wieder
eine riesige todo sache hier zu tun
bevor allerdings irgendwas davon
passiert eine schweige sekunde für die
kuh meine lieben freunde
ok pflanzen das feld weiter und dann
haben wir erst mal ganz ganz viel in die
kommentare geschrieben
luca du idiot die katze teleportiert
sich nicht
ich dachte die kommt mit die katze hätte
ich wohl auch mit in meinem boot nehmen
können von daher setzen wir uns das als
auch reinsetzen hier zurück sagt die an
sich das mal ein bisschen schöner im
brötchen und warum hat jeder dieser
meppen problem mit mir ich bin echt
richtig in love mit unserer inseln mdk
die sonne geht schon wieder fast unter
wir sehen schon das dörfchen baut sich
am horizont auf meine lieben freunde
die sonne ist untergegangen ist es nacht
ich habe ein bisschen schiss hier vorne
ist wie a ha da ist ja der apparat
ja ich habe ich nicht vermisst ihr seht
allerdings schon hier unten dass sich
ein lesepult mitgenommen habe das wird
nämlich auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben denn wir können einfach
fliegend einem arbeitslosen village oh
ja das sieht auch danach aus wir können
wohl zu irgendeinem villiger hingehen
und ihm das lesepult einfach vor die
nase setzen und dann wird er ein
bibliothekar doch wirklich kein eisen
grund bevor wir das allerdings machen
meine lieben freunde würde ich sagen
legen wir uns erstmal schlafen dass du
hast halt der nachtschicht hallo kannst
du runter geht von meinen schuhen
du bist ne katze also ich weiß nicht ob
ich da in den kommentaren mal wieder
verarscht wurde aber da stand vor
irgendeinem dorfbewohner soll ich das
ding einfach hinstellen
warum hat denn kein bock auf bücher
[Applaus]
[Musik]
buchbar wo haben wir und jetzt wird mir
gesagt dass ich jetzt auf ihn einfach
rechtsklick machen kann und also
entweder hast mich meine komplette welt
oder ihr gebt mir nur scheiß tipps bin
ich zu blöd
der läuft noch direkt darauf zu ist
einfach drauf wenn du siehst doch aus
wien
[Musik]
dieser ist ein auf essen bitte schreib
mir die kommentare was ich falsch mache
ich gehe allerdings mal nach hier oben
und neben ihm kurz einen fast weg war
ja aber ich brauche als aus
wissenschaftlichen gründen dann habe ich
gesehen hier unten abgedichtet rinden
baum krams genau heißt es brauche ich
aber auf jeden fall auch noch denn die
haben für heute klaren was ist hier die
mich die ganze zeit rum und dann ist sie
aber nicht da oder was ich habe heute
wieder einen architektonischen überfall
auf euch vor meiner lieben freunde denn
ich habe unten in den kommentaren
gelesen
[Musik]
man das sind werte drecks katzen ich
habe in den kommentaren gelesen dass
sich ein stall gewünscht wird und ich
habe sowohl zurück ich bin ich jeden von
euch und blöder bibliotheken babu werden
mir wurde in die kommentare geschrieben
dass ich doch einen stall für meine kühe
bauen kann das allererste was ich
allerdings eine stunde später der diese
katzen k
okay sie sitzt im boot das hat
wahrscheinlich mit der katze jetzt
zusammen zurück nach hause zu unserer
insel meine lieben freunde wo wir uns
dann die bauarbeiten für den stein
setzen werden die sonne geht hinter
unserer kleinen privaten insel hierunter
wir fahren hier vorne zu unserem
bootsanleger meine lieben freunde
kollision mit den schildkröten ich würde
allerdings sagen ich gehe ganz kurz
schlafen denn der baum hat mir auch
gesagt dass er einen neuen witz auf
lager so der bau hatten neun wird's egal
wie gut okay jetzt usain bolt dann
möchte ich jetzt auch noch kurz hier den
bootssteg endlich fertig machen bzw
diesen weg in der es ist ja mehr oder
weniger was ich mich schon immer gefragt
hat ist wie können so bothe eigentlich
schwimmen also schiffe generell das sind
millionen von tonnen an metall und die
schwimmen
allerdings die schwimmer einfach nicht
dass wir vorne trage ich jetzt mal ein
bisschen erde ab hier ist alles durch
löcher unsere ganze insel
ich habe das eigentlich ist hier unten
irgendwie nen event ich sage euch die
nächste folge wird auf jeden fall die
insel reparatur folge sein bevor wir das
allerdings machen müssten wir auch das
habe ich ganz viele geschrieben luca du
musst das mit einem zuckerrohr mehr im
blick behalten denn wir brauchen halt
das papier für unseren zauber tisch am
ende sind
wir sind schon auf einem guten weg mit
dem ganzen zuckerrohr brauchen
allerdings das leder und leder bekommen
wir halt von kühen und die müssen wir
dafür leider töten und deswegen wollte
ich hier einen stall hinbauen den möchte
ich auch auf jeden fall heute fertig
bauen dafür brauchen wir allerdings ganz
ganz ganz ganz viel holz und zwar
fichtenholz stämme die gab es ja hinten
unserem piratenschiff und ich brauche
dafür auch ganz ganz viel sand und den
sand gibt es ja auch hier vorne auf
unserer kleinen sandinsel von daher
kurze times will ich die sachen abbauen
so zurück auf unserer kleinen insel hier
angekommen meine lieben freunde ich leg
mich allerdings direkt mal eben schnell
schlafen weil ich kein bock habe sie
direkt wieder von monstern und keine
ahnung was überrascht werden von der
schinken mit dem schweinchen an unseren
füßchen ich habe jetzt eine menge sand
geholt und ich habe auch eine menge
fichtenholz sachen geholt die sache ist
das reicht noch nicht so ganz
wir brauchen immer noch ganz ganz viel
mehr holz das werde ich nachher hinten
an der dinge zu holen an unserer kleinen
holz insel
ich werde erstmal hier die höhe zu bauen
dass es so ein bisschen natürlicher
aussieht und hier alles so ein bisschen
aufstocken damit wir hier einfach ein
bisschen mehr platz haben der stall soll
hat nämlich kein normaler stall werden
das soll auch kein krasser tötungs steil
werden von wegen hey wir machen hier
ganz viel redstone hin und dann sterben
die ganzen tiere und so weiter und so
fort das will ich gar nicht ihr wisst
ich setze in diesem projekt mehr auf wir
gehen das ganze ruhig an und gelassen
und machen es halt ja lieber ästhetisch
und schön und dann dauert halt ein
bisschen länger als dass es irgendwie
total überrumpelt wird ich habe mir zwei
neue extra gemacht und auch noch die
vier fässer mitgenommen +16 dritter
eichenstämme einfach um euch schon mal
zu zeigen wie das hier alles aussehen
sollen mich 1 2 3 4 5 6 jeder noch ein
fass hindern in die richtung 12345 hier
ein fassen und hier vorne auch noch ein
fassen und ja auch noch mal 5 also so in
etwa soll der stadt aufgebaut werden
kommt ihr natürlich auch seinen weg noch
nach oben da muss der baum noch weg ich
würde allerdings sagen wir machen jetzt
erstmal ganz kurze time labs weil ich
nach da hinten muss und einige bäume
abfällen möchte den sie können den
später gott oh mein gott ich habe eine
ganze weile um mein gott ich wollte mal
rüber gehen
oh mein gott was war das was war das war
das wieder dieses meeresungeheuer was
umsetzen auch schon über den weg
gelaufen ist das war das was war das
was war das
sie hat nicht geschlagen
b
da ist er wieder der fisch ist dass ihm
ein neuer piranha oder irgendwie
alter schwede das kann doch nicht sein
bin ich so scheiße in diesem spiel
mein gott ich dachte ich wäre schon oben
gewesen wir machen jetzt das einzige was
ich kann in minecraft
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt ca 26 holz geholt ich
glaube dass das leider noch immer nicht
reichen wird allerdings müssen wir uns
damit jetzt erstmal zufrieden geben und
zurück fahren zu unserer kleinen insel
ich kann sich auf genug sagen ja ich bin
richtig happy darüber wie sich alles
entwickelt kurze runde schlafen meine
lieben freunde und dann können wir auch
schon direkt anfangen mit dem bau
unseres teils dafür brauchen wir mich
erstmal die eichenstämme und ich weiß
nicht ob ich noch habe genau hier so ein
bisschen zäune habe ich noch zehn tore
[Musik]
hier kommen nämlich jeweils zwei
eichenstämme drauf das bildet so ein
bisschen die er bilden die ecken sage
ich mal von unserem stall zack zack und
hier vorne auch noch zack zack ich habe
mir jetzt gerade hier fichtenholz zäune
und fichtenholz zaun tore gemacht ist
normal komplizierten namen
die kommen jetzt auf jeden fall hier
drauf so dass keine coole auch und
büchsen kern aus unserem kleinen stall
aber die werden doch schön haben ich
glaube jetzt nicht dass die da wirklich
weg gewonnen werden
hier kommen die zehn tore hin genau ich
glaube man sieht schon ein bisschen wo
es hingeht und jetzt kommt das
schwierigste
wir brauchen 56 lagerfeuer
das heißt insgesamt 36 eichenstämme ich
habe jetzt gerade einfach mal alles
fertig gemacht was wir für den bau hier
unten jetzt brauchen bevor ich die ganze
zeit die wirklich jetzt am hin und her
fahren bin und neues holz holen und so
weiter und so fort von dann fange ich
jetzt einfach mal an dass hier wird der
boden vom stall und ich finde sand als
stallboden für kühe passt irgendwie
nicht so richtig von da habe ich mich
dazu entschieden
hier einfach er da rein zu machen
allerdings so ein bisschen ist nicht
normale erde sondern hier zum beispiel
ganz normale erde jetzt nicht normale
erde sondern hier zum beispiel ganz
normale erde
diese normale erde werde ich allerdings
mit diesem gras blog hier vorne
verbinden sodass das normales gras wird
hier vorne oder werde ich ein paar
stellen werde ich so grobe erde hin
packen dementsprechend müsst ihr euch
vorstellen dass eigentlich nachher alles
grüne es bis auf sechs blöcke hier drin
die sieht man so ein bisschen die sind
so ein bisschen dunkler
hier kommt das zum beispiel so ein
bisschen gras hin dann habe ich mir
gedacht stelle ich hier rein strohballen
hin und hier damit wir so ein bisschen
und stall feeling haben und jetzt kommt
halt das ja wofür ich die 56 lagerfeuer
brauchte und zwar so dass das dach hier
werden und diese lagerfeuer in so ein
idiot gods wird der komplette stall
brennen aber ich sage euch das video
echt nice aussehen also wir gehen jetzt
hier darauf mit der schaufel und machen
die feuer
[Musik]
johannes hirsch im haus machen
damit sind wir allerdings noch nicht
fertig denn ihr seht schon ich mach hier
zu fichtenholz falltüren dran und daran
hänge ich hier und hier vorne eine
laterne plus laternen werde ich auch
noch das habe ich mir hier geschrien
schottet hierhin packen und hier und
hier auf die seite auch noch damit die
kühe komplett dingens haben beleuchtung
und jetzt beispielsweise hier vorne noch
gras hin und hier das können wir einfach
jetzt ein bisschen variieren vielleicht
auch hier neben um tier vorne direkt der
plan ist jetzt allerdings dass das gras
halt von hier runter wächst hier lang
geht um das dann hier alles grün ist bis
auf diese blöcke halt dann sieht alles
ein bisschen durcheinander aus dann
mache ich da noch so ein weg rein also
sowie der weg halt hier vorne es am grab
von der kuh also basically soll der weg
quasi hier so runter gehen weil man hier
zack zack zack die vielleicht noch so
ein bisschen so mal nach außen oder so
hier wieder so rüber bamm bamm bamm bamm
bamm zack zack hierüber und dann halt
hier runter und hier und dann soll hier
noch erde hin und hier auch und dann
geht der weg war sie hier so lange ist
er
und dann ist das halt der stall hier
sondern die küren die könnte ich immer
kurz im reinpacken weiter hier runter
sehr gut macht ihr das sehr sehr gut
und jetzt hier rein beide türen offen
zack zack zack kommt her hier rein rhein
spaziert rhein spaziert ich nehme das
weizen aus der hand macht die türen zu
ihr könnt ein bisschen spaß wir haben
miteinander da freut ihr euch doch dann
haben wir nämlich ein kleines neues
kindchen und rauchte was macht in unsere
kasse da drin wir sehen hier hinten
schon dass die sonne untergeht setzen
uns dann unser lagerfeuer beobachten
einfach mal ja ich sitze also sitzt man
natürlich immer am lagerfeuer ich gehe
lieber mal nach oben und beobachte von
hier den sonnenuntergang beziehungsweise
dem mondaufgang meiner lieben freund
blödmann also meine lieben freunde wenn
euch die heutige episode minecraft mit
luca gefallen hat dann das kann einen
daumen hoch und ein video hier da
abonniert main kanal weil es noch kein
teil der lucio seit dadurch verpasst ihr
keine neuen folgen mehr und übermorgen
um 20 uhr
nämlich eine neue folge wir kümmern uns
wirklich endlich um die insel reparatur
ich freue mich auf jeden fall ich hoffe
ihr seid wieder mit dabei bei unserer
kleinen reise hier und bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]